well joining us now are the nightclub
owner and entrepreneur and attendee of
the bald Peter Stringfellow and Susy
Boniface the journalist and author of
the free Street Fox blog and Twitter
site welcome to both do you buy anything
Peter Stringfellow
well and we went for the silent auction
for tea and buns and cakes with Boris
Johnson to discuss his new book Winston
Churchill so my wife said look let's put
in three thousand because it was two
thousand a time said great so she saw a
name up there for half a second so
suddenly went four thousand five
thousand and I think it went for seven
and a half thousand but luckily is a
good friend so that was all right
and what motivates you to get involved
is it because you just want to show your
loyalty to the party or because he
genuinely wants me or as Johnson what
made you want to be I know loads of
party and it was fun because I'm a great
fan of Boris I think is wonderful I
should be the deputy prime minister
that's my opinion but let's move on by
that one yeah it's also but the whole
part of it is yeah my lunch into the
party but well minority to the UK if the
Conservatives weren't doing the right
thing they won't have my support they
are doing the right thing and last night
was superb it was so aspirational and
inspiration those two always go together
and they were all it was great energy
and it felt like Britain was really only
two it miss Suzy oh no I don't think a
Tory supporter but why do you bid for I
am ambidextrous is from a concerned I
don't support him suppose I he's gone
with a rich escort away to a bit but
anything I would have been a gazillion
pounds for dinner with Boris and I would
have not paid and waited fumes chased me
for it or I might have I might have big
one of my old used toenails for a
roasted Michael Gove and the problem
with a lot of the stuff that was up for
us some of it was busy holidays and
trips on private jets and stuff which
most people were quite like as long as
it doesn't come attached to Eric Pickles
but it's a lot of these gifts and then
the things you could bid for we're very
very odd I'm sorry Peter but I really
anyone any normal sane human being
wouldn't want to go shoe shopping with
Theresa May it would be limited fun the
woman's never question starting I may
get the impression you don't like
anybody you don't like there you don't
see what about the roast chicken
I like them all I need two resumes
wonderful and is it possibly a future
Brad nice I like her very much
we have tea with Boris yeah if you
wanted it why'd you I don't have TVs
Boris had a break between Boris and
winter supper with Boris but I wouldn't
never drink the virus to be oh I love
English wonderful and very intelligent
very smart very clever but why did you
need to listen to him sell you his book
I mean that seems a strange thing to be
reading books among on wrong with
sensation I read I haven't read the
breeze I've read lots of other thing
about my situation I feel I know enough
about ways
I mean if Boris was gonna do lap dancing
or bid for that I'd be prepared to try
to get in there one spring kind of money
obviously we know that parties are short
of money and that's why they do these
events - not after lies and - right oh
yeah exactly battery over three million
pounds do you think in the end I mean
labour has yeah thousand pound of plate
dinners as well do you think it actually
does the parties any good oh you know
very much so I mean I think some people
just think it's incredibly sort of
portion extravagant and not really in
turn I know let's use that silly would
dissolve in posh some young my god when
I was a kid in the forties that was
using comics it's not a real word you
say for example Whittle Cameron's ban
champagne because he thinks people think
it yeah I know and I know you're working
but I was silly and he knows it was and
champagnes wonderful and everybody like
champagne you're gonna get married what
are we gonna do oh you just like if the
look but when you've got lots like
pheasant shooting and disco yelling okay
okay listen up a minute pheasant yeah
image for the party though at a time of
austerity I'm gonna shoot I mean you
telling me that somebody for labor is
never shot a pheasant I don't let's be
silly I mean we may know it now Jeff
I've never heard of a later Labor MP
shooting pheasants I know I suppose I'll
tell you why I will shake hands with you
now and will because you're very smart
you know love people and that Westport
I'm Mickey sensible
100 pound for charity I reckon there is
in you said there isn't a hundred I
think there's a Labour MP shop corner
present shoot wait wait why not anybody
can question
love pheasant chicken but would never
shoot one I would never kill rings fused
well I'm not gonna baby steps don't tell
me it's fine I love animals I do these
auctions all party parties need to try
and find some way to I get their
donations up they've also they're going
to look at ways of reforming party
political funding I'm not entirely sure
that getting a group of people in who
with the greatest of respect Peter they
think a very rich and whose pockets they
can pick to try and fund their campaigns
it the way they're if we don't see that
way we honestly don't see that um my my
time as a water not sugary champ and I
could never put my money do you think do
you think you were invited because
they're desperate to know how you think
they should run the country are you
David rings me up every day asking me my
opinion that means quite a mess but you
you you wear those Apeco you were
supporting them well you know but I'm
supposed to conserve it ever since I
left Sheffield as a kid and I realized
it was such a thing as a mortgage nobody
told me that chef it was a very
socialist and probably just about like a
Southie option
yes well the point of it is that I
became an aspirational person without
knowing what the murder meant and Tom
Sheffield onwards and as much as I like
Sheffield aspiration inspiration is what
was there my bucket loads of it last
night and if the Great Britain could
catch that energy
we'd have no problems it was wonderful
full of any three grand for stuff we
have with money but so do me worldly
success what would you donate if you
were asked to donate a prize for a cause
that you did support what would you do
it I would donate the abilities of
apostrophes because I think that's a
terrible paucity in British life at the
moment people don't know how to use
apostrophes correct have you got a
phosphorus on string first use those
dots in when it when I'm emailing sad
but yes I know
gamba and I know that's wrong because
how do I know that's terrible but but I
would do it for me quote it's alright me
back from GMO debate another time I'm
sure people know most I'll send this to
be election dog apostrophe